statt und wir gehen direkt live zu paul
ronzheimer nach kiew ja paul du hast
diese schrecklichen bilder gestern für
uns gemacht was hat das ausgelöst india
und den kollegen die mit euch dort waren
wir haben es als wahnsinnig wichtig
empfunden dass zu protokollieren was
dort passiert ist und so grausam das ist
das ist unsere arbeit anderer die wir
machen müssen
und ich glaube es ist etwas was die welt
sehen muss diese bilder
dieses mannes der
kartoffel holen gegangen ist und
erschossen wurde
vor allem
dieses bild geht mir nicht so nicht mehr
aus dem kopf genauso wie bilder von
anderen leichen die dort auf der straße
lagen und als wir dort hinkommen es war
gestern mittag ungefähr liegen 12
egal wo man hingeschaut hat überall
leichen überall zivilisten über menschen
die nicht militärisch gekleidet waren
die klar ersichtlich einige auf dem
fahrrad andere die zu fuß unterwegs
waren hingerichtet teilweise per
kopfschuss
mit den händen verbunden nach hinten
china tatsächlich worte
japan wirklich
unfassbare grausamkeit dinge bilder
wirklich von denen ich mir nicht hätte
vorstellen können dass sie jemals so
geschehen was glaubst du was steckt
dahinter warum tun die russen das ist
das
gezielt angstmacherei was glaubst du
warum warum werden hier zivilisten
gezielt abgeschlachtet
man muss davon ausgehen dass der plan
der russischen armee war wenn wir uns
anschauen welche pläne mann hatte bei
der übernahme von städten da ging es
darum ganz gezielt auch menschen zu
erschießen da ging es darum auch ganz
gezielt städte zu übernehmen da ging es
darum ganz gezielt leute aus zu löschen
die nicht mehr in das passen was die
russische armee aus kiew aus anderen
städten machen wollte dann ging es vor
allem um politische opposition um die
leute die wichtig sind für die
ukrainische
zivilgesellschaft das ist ja alles
niedergeschrieben es gibt diese pläne
geheimdienste haben davor gewarnt
geheimdienste haben vor dem krieg mein
kollege julian rogge hat das damals
aufgeschrieben im dezember haben davor
gewarnt von massentötung die passieren
für vor massentötung nach übernahme der
russischen armee
diese geheimdienstlichen erkenntnisse
jetzt im zusammenhang stehen mit dem was
die botschaft passiert ist das kann ich
nicht sagen das muss untersucht werden
was genau wie dort passiert ist
natürlich versuchen auch wir heute
wieder mehr darüber zu erfahren weitere
augenzeugen zu sprechen aber am ende
muss man davon ausgehen dass das ganze
system hatte und einen befehl
und trotzdem immer wieder die
öffentlichen statements der russen nein
wir greifen keine zivilisten an paul wir
wollen noch mal gemeinsam mit dir
reinhören in den ton von wladimir
klitschko war es gestern mit beiden
klitschko-brüdern vor ort was wladimir
zu diesen schrecklichen bildern gesagt
hat die zivilisten die hier die straße
unterliegen wagen sind die herren dir
man sieht dass sie im kopf
geschossen worden und
exekutiert wird das gerät von
das was macht mut in der ukraine wo die
samen in die ukraine ist ein vollkommen
das ist kein
special operations
von
paul am international ist das entsetzen
natürlich große über dieses massaker von
botschaft markiert das jetzt tatsächlich
noch einmal eine neue zeitenwende in
diesem krieg ist das jetzt noch mal eine
ganz neue dimension die eventuell auch
noch mal international zu neuen
sanktionen führen könnte zu
weiterreichenden handlungen
das ist eine neue dimension sandra
für die das ist eine neue dimension
etwas das
ja dass viele für unvorstellbar gehalten
haben aber das eben passiert ist das ist
die realität das ist passiert und es
muss man immer wieder zeigen und man
muss es immer wieder klar machen weil
das ist den menschen von butscher
passiert und ich hatte gestern abend
gestern nacht kontakt zu deutschen
politikern und zu anderen politikern die
mir geschrieben haben und ihn auch
näheres wissen wollten
mir fehlen wirklich die worte das zu
beschreiben teilweise aber
es muss weitere konsequenzen haben dann
wurden menschen auf offener straße
abgeschlachtet von der russischen armee
zivilist
wenn das keine weiteren konsequenzen hat
dann weiß ich auch nicht paul weitere
konsequenzen hat auch unser
bundeskanzler olaf scholz gestern abend
noch angekündigt und wir hören auch noch
mal gemeinsam mit dir ein in seinen
staten
meine damen und herren in diesen stunden
erreichen uns furchtbare und grauen der
regener aufnahmen aus der ukraine
wir sehen dutzende erschossene
zivilisten buch da ein gebiet nördlich
von kiew das bis vor wenigen tagen vom
russischen militär kontrolliert worden
ist straßen übersät mit leichen
notdürftig verscharrt körper
es ist von frauen kindern und alten die
rede die unter den opfern sind
die ermordung von zivilisten ist ein
kriegsverbrechen
diese verbrechen der russischen
streitkräfte müssen wir schonungslos
aufklären ich verlange dass
internationale organisationen wie das
internationale komitee vom roten kreuz
zugang erhalten zu diesen gebieten und
die gräueltaten dokumentieren die täter
und ihre auftraggeber müssen zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden
der krieg in der ukraine befindet sich
in der sechsten woche tausende
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer sind ihm
schon zum opfer gefallen und das töten
geht unvermindert weiter
ich fordere präsident putin und russland
auf endlich in einen waffenstillstand
einzuwilligen und die kampfhandlungen
einzustellen
es ist ein furchtbarer ein sinnloser ein
durch nichts zu rechtfertigen der krieg
der unendlich viel leid erzeugt und
niemandem nutzt er muss aufhören
wir werden im kreis der verbündeten in
den nächsten tagen weitere maßnahmen
beschließen die präsident putin und
seine unterstützer werden die folgen
spüren und wir werden der ukraine
weiterhin waffen zur verfügung stellen
damit sie sich gegen die russische
invasion verteidigen kann
vielen dank
paule dieses statement von bundeskanzler
scholze mein aufruf sozusagen noch mal
an die truppen sich zu einigen frieden
zu schließen die kampfhandlungen
niederzulegen das wird ja sicherlich
nicht passieren reicht das reicht so ein
statement jetzt
ich denke der bundesrat vor allem offen
gelassen welche sanktionen jetzt
verschärft werden könnten was nicht nur
daran liegen mag dass deutschland da
unentschlossen scheint sondern eben dass
man alle europäischen länder
gemeinsam an einen tisch haben will und
nicht dass einzelne länder vorpreschen
das ist auch der politik so ein bisschen
von olaf scholz muss man sagen ja will
erst sozusagen sichergehen dass
bestimmte dinge in eine richtung geben
vor sich festlegen bevor er sich
öffentlich äußert und sagt das und das
will ich ich höre das ist eine
verschärfung von sanktionen geben soll
aber noch nicht ein öl und gas folgt das
ist das was ich höre und ich weise
verändert sich das heute noch mal im
laufe des tages aber das ist der stand
gestern nacht sage ich ja mal über die
sorge immer noch groß ist dass man so
sind diejenigen oder so argumentieren
diejenigen die dagegen sind dass man das
momentan der deutschen wirtschaft nicht
zumuten könne beziehungsweise
das dass kollateralschäden haben würde
das ist das was diejenigen argumentieren
und dass man andere sanktion versuche
jetzt bei vielen dank nach kiew danke
für diese eindrücklichen unfassbaren
bilder die du uns immer wieder aus der
ukraine 6 die wir hier tatsächlich
zeigen müssen diese gräueltaten die
putins armee anrichtet und man merkt
auch wie sehr dir das
nicht zusetzt was weiter auf dich auf